alors figurez-vous que aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler des blaireaux et je
pense que c'est un sujet qui vous
touchent personnellement parce que vous
connaissez tous dans votre entourage
un voire plusieurs blaireau alors le
blaireau est un animal nocturne
son poil est blanc et gris clair avec
des petites pointes plus foncée par
endroits on l'appelle aussi le blaireau
européen pour bien son nom mais le
blaireau est un animal qui m'intéresse
particulièrement parce qu'il ne change
pas de terrier et même si on le déloge
de son premier terrier il va pas partir
à des dizaines des centaines de
kilomètres en faire un autre non il va
aller à quelques mètres du premier pour
en creuser un nouveau et moi ça me parle
parce que professionnellement parlant
je suis un blaireau un vrai de vrai je
n'ai jamais quitté ma terre natale
l'auvergne le puy-de-dôme
clermont-ferrand
je n'ai jamais quitter ses terres pour
monter à paris
c'est pas fini encore je suis écrivain
mon métier consiste la moitié du temps à
raconter des histoires à inventer des
histoires à en écrire et l'autre moitié
du temps à répondre à cette question
agaçante que beaucoup de gens posent
cette question c'est mais c'est quoi
votre vrai métier dans la vie mon vrai
métier c'est d'écrire des livres et il
se trouve que pour moi depuis quelques
temps ça marche bien et c'est génial
c'est génial de se lever le matin et de
faire ce qu'on aime faire mais néanmoins
il ya une autre question bien plus
agaçantes que la première est bien plus
cruelle aussi et c'est de ça dont je
vais parler aujourd'hui
et cette question c'est avec tout ce qui
vous arrive actuellement
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas allé habiter à
paris
c'est étrange ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait partir pour réussir
pire encore il faudrait aller habiter
ailleurs pour prouver qu'on a réussi
déjà la réussite c'est pas un concept
général clair objectif la réussite c'est
un sentiment personnel c'est une
sensation individuel c'est comme votre
sexualité ça ne regarde que vous surtout
si vous êtes célibataire
la réussite ne peut pas être énoncé de
façon claire et général tout comme on ne
peut pas annoncer de façon claire et
générale la valeur d'une oeuvre ou d'une
création et c'est d'ailleurs dans la
création littéraire classique française
que sept ans ce mythe du transfert de la
province à la capitale chez balzac chez
zola chez maupassant flaubert stendhal
c'est paris à nous deux il faut monter
pour réussir il faut y aller parce que
dans la littérature française
la campagne et les petites villes de
campagne c'est salissant faire de
l'argent dans l'agriculture c'est
beaucoup moins noble que faire de
l'argent dans l'art dans la politique ou
dans l'économie mais il ya autre chose
dans cette question et c'est beaucoup
plus gênant que le reste c'est que tous
les gens qui l'ont posé cette question
s'était jamais des parisiens alors
parenthèse un vrai parisien ça n'existe
pas un parisien de souche à parisien
aujourd'hui c'est un provincial qui
acceptent de payer 8 euros pour boire
une bière on est d'accord ok donc c'est
pas des parisiens qui m'ont posé cette
question
c'est des clermontois c'est des gens
d'ici et quand il me la posent cette
question j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
déçus que je les ai déçus alors moi je
me demande mais quel est le problème
avec nos villes et nos petites villes en
y réfléchissant bien je pense que le
lien qu'on entretient avec son lieu de
naissance et son lieu de vie quand on
n'a pas pu partir c'est le même lien
qu'on entretient avec ses parents à
l'adolescence on les aime bien mais nous
foutent un peu la honte quand même vous
vous souvenez je pense de ces soirées à
l'adolescence quand vos parents y venez
vous chercher et c'est un moment un peu
gênant est un peu compliqué pour tout le
monde d'ailleurs
et là c'est pareil et en d'autres termes
ça voudrait dire que la campagne
que les petites villes de campagne que
ce qu'on appelle très vulgairement la
provence ne serait pas digne du talent
de ceux qui sont nés je trouve que c'est
une idée extrêmement répandu et très
triste je ne crois pas que l'herbe soit
plus verte ailleurs
surtout quand on habite en auvergne je
crois surtout qu'on est en train
d'assister à un syndrome instagram qui
est le résultat contemporain de ce qui
était déjà présent dans la littérature
classique
le syndrome instagram ça veut dire qu'on
a tous des filtres dans la tête qui
s'allument des conventions paris dès
qu'on parle de la capitale des filtres
sur les images qui nous viennent des
lieux qu'on pourrait visiter des cafés
on pourrait s'asseoir des gens qu'on
pourrait découvrir des filtres sur le
rêve de cette fabuleuse soirée on
pourrait rencontrer la personne qui va
changer le cours de notre vie dans le
milieu parisien ce milieu moi je sais
même pas s'il a existé je sais même pas
s'ils existent actuellement ce milieu
parce que j'ai préféré rester sur les
bords tranquillement pourquoi chers
clermontois devriez-vous partir pour
réussir pourquoi devriez-vous fatalement
succombé aux fantasmes du grand départ
après tout si on a atteint ce point de
réussite à partir duquel on peut faire
uniquement ce qu'on veut il me semble
aussi qu'on peut le faire d'où on veut
dans cette question mais vous n'êtes pas
allé habiter à paris il ya quand même
cette idée que paris serait à la fois la
cause et la conséquence de la réussite
et c'est un peu absurde
un petit peu quand même c'est un peu
absurde parce que aujourd'hui on peut
écrire un livre de n'importe où même
dans des terres très reculés comme le
cantal où la bretagne
on peut écrire un livre et l'envoyer par
la poste partout dans le monde
pour un montant qui sera toujours moins
cher que le café en terrasse rue de
rivoli
on a les moyens actuellement de faire ce
qu'on veut d'où on veut je pense que ce
qui m'étonne le plus c'est à quel point
parfois on est mal à l'aise avec son
lieu de naissance avec son lieu
d'apprentissage comme si pour les autres
pour le regard extérieur comme si rester
dans cet endroit c'était aussi rester
dans l'enfance rester dans l'adolescence
refusé de passer à l'âge adulte et dans
un même mouvement refuser la possibilité
de la réussite ou la possibilité de
l'échec
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui la vraie
réussite c'est de pouvoir dire j'ai les
moyens de choisir le lieu où je me sens
bien j'ai la force d'aller où je veux et
de rester où je veux et très sincèrement
je ne crois pas que la réussite
personnelle soit une question de lieu
mais que le lieu qu'ont choisi lui est
une question de réussite personnelle
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]